A spokesperson for Google said that,...
…while chatbots can imitate conversation, they are not free thinking,...
…but, what made the company's former employees speak out?
Well, let's bring you some insights into that.
I'm joined by our technology editor, Zoey Kleinman, who is with us here today.
Zoey, what is all this about?
It's a fascinating story, isn't it?
So, Google created an artificial intelligence project which it called LaMDA,...
…and it was designed to generate chatbots.
Chatbots are the things you see when you go online,...
…you know, a little box pops up.
"Can I help you?"
"Can I", you know, "book your flight?"
"Can I advise you?"
That sort of thing.
Google wanted to make them as realistic as possible.
It's spent about five years now creating this.
The senior engineer says he had a chat with it, a conversation.
He kind of interviewed it.
He's published a really long blog...
…but it's a very interesting read in which he asked it a series of questions,...
…and the responses that it gave were fascinating on a range of subjects.
And he asked it things like,...
…"do you like the story of Les Misérables?"
…and this chatbot talked about feeling sorry for one of the characters.
It talks about being afraid of death, being afraid of being switched off.
It talks about understanding feelings of happiness and sadness.
And it's just not what you would expect, is it, from...
…something that is, that has been created, to generate speech.